okay let's talk about that middle-class
famous tour baby those sweet sweet live
shows
about to be kicking into high gear it's
a stand-up comedy show with a little ayg
that we play with the crowd great way to
introduce new people to the show so grab
the squad grab the homies grab the bozos
grab your best girl grab your best guy
and come out and see us yeah guys uh
first date is gonna be red bank new
jersey that it will sell out get those
tickets and we're in seattle portland
kansas city springfield st louis
nashville come on then up there to indy
get your tickets like big man said it's
a great time these live shows are
bonkers you've seen the clips link in
the description do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they go to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she is disappeared oh
no on the lamb okay the last thing she
said to me is anybody from fanduel shows
up at the house you don't know me
my co-host is coming at you right next
to me i got him technically he's the ceo
of ru garbage bit of international
business man he is the prince of park
avenue but always the king of the
boardwalk give it up for kj kevin james
ryan talking
i got the giggles early uh thanks for
tuning in everybody make sure you review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true to roof cooking and then obviously
patreon.com the greatest goddamn website
of all time check it the [ __ ] out yes
sir you don't know what you're missing
you don't you're missing millions upon
millions of hours of content already and
that hard feelings too we really let the
hair go down
but how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good we love them
you love them give it up for toby
mcmullen everybody what's up dudes
what's cooking t-bone no loving the
frames buddy thanks i got my new glasses
you're the old you're the only guy who
looks dumber with glasses
trying to take my sats again
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly and i [ __ ] mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he's family at this point
he's always been we love him [ __ ]
absolutely amazing and here's the
[ __ ] turkey right now he has got a
brand new netflix special out right now
called nocturnal admissions do us a
favor and give it up for one of the most
classiest guys to ever sit at [ __ ]
sure of course mr paul version
there's a polly in the building
this is like my third yeah
that's a real [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's three times i've been here
yeah [ __ ] steph curry doing this this is
my third time
are you yeah dude the snl hosts right to
get a jacket for five times there you go
so when i gum five i wanna are you
garbage one of your [ __ ] coors light
jackets
getting monograms there's cousin paulie
on it a pair of foley's old sneakers
well since you brought that up we
actually have a little gift for you yes
all right we know you're a classy guy
listen this is a [ __ ] big deal
paulie's got a special out on netflix it
is literally the [ __ ] talk of the
town everybody's saying how [ __ ]
amazing second major special by the way
second major special anybody can do one
they're giving them out yeah anybody can
do one everybody can do it throw it on
youtube whatever if you want to see me
probably what i'm going to do if you
want to see my first one you got to hunt
down a comedy central executive
show he's got it under the bed somewhere
you got to go to a theater and marry you
take a look at that
yikes but buddy everybody's saying this
is you know there's specials then
there's something that's special and the
word on the street this is truly special
and we wanted to give you this
bottle of wine
oh dude thank you so much
of course appreciate it i figured you
could take that home when the time's
right you got a couple of steaks on the
grill take it home i'm sipping on a car
ride tonight stuck in traffic
on the belt that's silly i'll be
shipping us like a 40 and [ __ ] 96.
he's got a straw in it
driving down the street with a crazy
straw and a bottle of cake bread what
would the person next to me if you like
[Laughter]
that's awesome man yeah i'm really
excited congratulations i worked real
hard on the hour and then and then uh
pandemic hit and it actually allowed me
to kind of work on some jokes even more
okay so um it came together everybody
who saw people that i really love and
respect are saying something nice
you're still always like hey man when it
comes out but i know that this is the
best work i've done as far as anything
that the public is gonna see so uh yeah
i'm just gonna you know leave it to to
everybody that watches it and hope for
the best it's fair i was there i was
that you were i was at the taping i
opened up uh struggled a little bit
lie but
isn't that that's how comics remember
that
biggest night of your life yeah yeah
yeah he's gonna do it congratulations
here's wine dude my second joke
my second joke was flat dude i tried
ripping i wasn't there you know what i
mean how many jokes can you make you
know you [ __ ] remember the waitress
was loud at that second table she
dropped the glass i'll never forget a
hand to god hand to god i'll never
forget
put that guy in the back eating the pop
are you crazy too we're so nuts we
remember [ __ ] everything it's
actually sick i know i know but you
[ __ ] murdered like it was one of
those where like
cause you're you know i'm nervous
watching you because i'm like oh [ __ ]
this is a big there's it's a production
yeah yeah it's a proper [ __ ]
production yeah um directed by pete
davidson i mean you got the [ __ ]
crane it's it's crazy yeah it's a
[ __ ] movie it is nuts like the night
you do it and you just start seeing the
biggest agents and you know and pete
davidson reached out to me and we were
he's like hey man i'd love to i'd love
to direct this thing so he was there and
he he's so please just do whatever he is
yeah he's smoking six with pete davidson
in the locker room that's real [ __ ]
cool oh he's the best he's the best dude
he's the most misunderstood like he's
the [ __ ] chillest dude so he was
there but everybody's there my wife and
all these people and i'm like just get
the wheels in i'm in the back like just
get the wheels in the air like start
cooking and he starts murdering i was
like all right
and they did i said you know my wife was
like you guys will love this [ __ ]
because we're on are you garbage and i'm
you know i'm clearly not
don't
you forget that out there how many i
don't know how many episodes i got to be
on before you guys could just erase the
let's just talk give you a [ __ ] nice
bite there's a diet
yeah there's a real big contrast here
it's got dip spin in it
no but i i said to my i said to my
wife's like should we get some champagne
out here for after the show and i said
yeah i said get the bottle of dom you
know and then and then i go i go two
bottles
i go i did two specials i want two
bottles of dom so i was holding them
like two trophies and i said to her i go
but if you get this he was there he's
got the goggles on like he wanted
he's got the green room was all tart out
i'm dumping it on my wife's head
[Music]
[Laughter]
i got the makeup lady in the headlock
squirting her face
uh no these are all smoking cigars
no and i said to my wife i go listen
here's the deal if you get the bottles
of dom on ice which i knew she would i
said we're going strawberries and and
she goes i go i need strawberries with
it and i get off stage i come in and
there's just two bottles of dom on ice
and just a vat of strawberries he likes
his fresh fruits
you take a little bite of it and you
dump the rest in the i mean yeah it was
it was it was a
yeah we've traveled i opened up for you
for you know for a long time i i'm known
as a and i think you could attest to
this i'm a very easygoing laid-back dude
of course but i there are certain things
where you're just like oh he's got he's
i mean he like is demanding stronger
particularly you're classy i'm
particularly like things done right but
i'll never [ __ ] on the people like if
they don't do it no you know i'll
quietly i'll hold a grudge for 20 25
years but i ain't gonna [ __ ] on them if
you're drinking a bottle of miller high
life with a laffy catcher
i'm not gonna say nothing in your face
but i'm gonna trash you in the car yeah
well what happened is i if they were
like paul we couldn't get the
strawberries i'd be like it's fine then
i'd call kevin what the [ __ ] was that
i'm [ __ ] telling you i'm telling my
agent i'm not [ __ ] coming back i'm
over eating a little bit
quite frankly i don't like the bathroom
in the hotel
what the [ __ ] is it you know there was a
hair on that and then he would hear it
and then we would go out and eat and
forget about it are you a move the room
guy have you ever moved the room at the
hotel hey i don't like this you set me
up with something else no i'm not i'm
not a move the room guy but i'm uh um if
it's like if i could see that it's like
three stars uh-huh like lie to me if
it's three stars just spruce it up so i
i think it's close to four sure but
don't show me it's three
like i already know i'm in a [ __ ] hole
so let's lie make sure i gotta sleep
here for two nights make sure the remote
has a back to it
duct tape [ __ ] remote dude dumb
things like make the towel an animal
makes me better yeah yeah yeah you know
what i'm gonna make the flower out of it
yeah you like the toilet paper with the
little fold there i do the fold in the
sticker even though it's like almost
gone like the rolls like half empty yeah
just fold it and put a sticker on it
make me feel nice i agree with paul you
know what i do when i first get done i
go you guys got movie this is my way to
go you guys got movies in the room and
then they go what do you mean like move
and then when i say that and they
already say no i mean the movies you
could purchase yeah yeah yeah but you
know sometimes they just got like hbo
so i always go hey you guys got movie in
room to order and they go no and i just
that's when i know it's
you're in for only adam and eve
now will you uh
send them a couple hustlers and if they
just have show time it's a problem
uh you [ __ ] suckers couldn't get hbo in
here i mean what do you got a family
plan
he's i'm putting my own netflix password
like that's bad too just stay somewhere
you're like you're texting your wife
what the login is for [ __ ] netflix
how many times have you talked you were
just doing that you were screaming at
your girlfriend what's the login
uh that's a bad luck will you how do you
feel if you get back will you dabble in
like the little uh a lot of the things
don't have mini bars now they have like
the little section in the lobby where
you can get like some water
no you don't mess with like a little
convenience store no downstairs oh you
mean the downstairs downstairs yeah yeah
i'll go and get something like i think
we're talking about the vending machine
i thought you meant like the vending
machine yeah
i'm no stranger
yeah you're getting ice it's an impulse
buy what do you want no nothing's worse
than seeing a guy barefoot with a bucket
of ice at two in the morning
it's like you [ __ ] alcoholic go to
bed dude enough the bed yeah we're
wearing a [ __ ] holiday inn express
next to the airport shut it guys got to
put his last two cores in a bucket at 10
30 in the morning um no i'll i'll go
down there i'll get a water for the next
day i'll get like a like a breakfast bar
something something if i'm hungry um i
don't like when they don't have a
restaurant in the place that's a tough
look that's classy you know because you
like to come in after a show let's say
it's 11. hey can i get wings sometimes
oh no but we have
life savers
upstairs eating toothpaste dude i did
one you know the one that they have the
it's the tuna it's a can of tuna with
the with the crackers and the thing to
scoop wow yeah i know you're jammed up i
was almost thinking about you guys when
i was doing it what part of siberia
yes
who booked siberia dude the spoon for it
was this big i felt like it was like one
of those ice cream tasters
i felt like the biggest piece of [ __ ]
i'm sitting at the desk with this baby
thing and i'm trying to get i'm trying
to equal it on the cracker no mayo is
there mayo no no it's it's it's like
pre-mixed dry tuna no it's uh it's
bumble bee reg mixed tuna okay but in
the can
then you unseal it and it comes with a
scooper and you put it on the crackers
that it comes with but when you're
jammed up and hungry yeah trust me i
know ma'am i can't get a steak i can't
get a burger i got something i'm not
eating beef jerky for dinner
they got a porterhouse in a can
a little fork and knife
i assume since you mentioned the
barefoot thing if say you're at a hotel
they got the pool whatever you go down
before the show will you do the pool
will you do a dip
if it's if it's a five star really yeah
if it's a if it's if i'll do the pool if
it's got a steam room and a sauna oh we
were in a hampton inn oh man we were
somewhere i thought it was like a disney
it looked like we were at cancun dude we
were [ __ ] doing chicken fights
but will you walk around the hotel
barefoot no i didn't even listen to the
question
as soon as you said walk around it's
like my feet are wrapped up in nike
leather that's what it is and it's
90 gonna be white yeah like a
five-year-old made these shoes you're
gonna sit in a steam room with jordan's
eyes
chainsaw oh the chain's [ __ ] i keep
the chains on even though they get hot
it's all burnt i got a [ __ ] branding
i got a branding on around the neck but
they stay on do you keep them on when
you shower yes you do so they never come
off this is part of me dude really dude
this is part of me okay this is like if
you took this away my powers would go
[Laughter]
away start bombing i'm like like a
christopher reeve when he lost his
powers in his in superman dude
i don't know what netflix paid you but
it wasn't enough
paulie's all right gang
paulie's the best gotta love that
version oh dude you guys are the best
man i i love i i literally there are
there's a and i mean this i mean this
dude this is actually a serious thing i
was thinking about this the other night
there's a few things in comedy that
really have brought me joy and and your
guys success and the success of this
show is one of those things when i when
i think about it because i know where
you guys came from and what you guys do
and and it kind of reminds me of because
nobody gave a [ __ ] about me for 14 years
yeah so for for this to be like this
it's just it's one of those things where
i look up and i just smile and i want
you guys to have the [ __ ] world which
you what you're going to have thank you
that means so much coming from you
honestly we love you and uh did i get
that bottle of jameson
you're swapping it out
i'm leaving with mountain dew and easy
cheese
hey take the dude don't touch the cheese
i'm making a charcuterie board later
um vacations hotels all that kind of
stuff traveling around yeah as things
get bigger for you which you know you're
on a [ __ ] rocket ship um
where do you see
what would be like a like a yeah like a
dream vacation dream vacation dream
destination do you want to stay in the
house do you want to get a bigger house
do you want to move back to the city
what do you want to do oh you guys are
asking really good questions because i
assume you've been thinking about you
know i'm working on that
here's what i'm doing okay so i live up
i live elevate i live like eight eight
hundred percent countries
i'm out in the country i'm high up i got
the view of the mountains but we want to
up we want to so the land we have the
house is nice and and and new looking
and great but it's you didn't build that
right that was there no we didn't build
it okay um and the property in the lot
is crazy the property is
proper bananas right we have this yeah
and like my wife's got this amazing
garden so but we wanted to move and
level up a little bit
so we after a long time long story short
we're like let's just [ __ ] let's just
throw another house on this house let's
just [ __ ] whatever i don't give a
[ __ ] what it costs
she wasn't well not say you don't care
what it costs
you because yeah because she's screaming
at her
i go i go i'll throw a [ __ ] million
and a half
she's like then we could get another
house i go no we're [ __ ] turning this
house and then she goes we're getting a
pool too but i'm doing the new
fiberglass pool you heard about this no
oh it's a yeah i think i do know [ __ ]
yeah so what they do is they just dig
the hole and they apply a [ __ ] truck
comes and just puts it in okay it needs
no maintenance really it's incredible
it's incredibly done and then you can
build around it so i think we're going
to do that and through the stones or
whatever you want to around it yeah
there's a couple of italian guys that do
the stones italians love stone dude you
guys we're all masons
watch an italian just marvel at a piece
of rock or marble and they just talk
about it [ __ ] born with a wet saw in
there
nothing like cutting with a wet saw i'll
tell you that's a good feeling oh yeah
no so so but i wanted to do grease and
sicily because i'm greek and sicilian
uh-huh so let's take but have you been
no i've been to italy twice okay but
i've never been like actually went to
sicily and greece especially in the
towns that i'm from so i wanted to do it
but vladimir putin [ __ ] it up because
when that [ __ ] happened
well i gotta the blame's gotta go
somewhere
you hear that you bdid piece of [ __ ]
yeah i know i'll only get your [ __ ] up
and go oh you're pride kevin only a
prideful grudge guy like me just has to
go it's putin's fault that's why i'm not
saying [ __ ] project in venice right
now somebody i'm blaming putin on
problems with my girlfriend i don't know
you're talking i'm throwing his name
around everywhere
no so and i made the mistake we made a
mistake stacey's like should we maybe
not go because it was right when they
invaded ukraine sure and it was like
right when that's like i don't know what
the [ __ ] gonna happen of course we
don't know what's gonna happen if
there's you know
uh you know what is it called on the top
of the uh on the top of the newspaper is
world war iii coming and then you hear
another headline world war three maybe
and they start saying like americans
don't travel
[Laughter]
so i said to stacy i go what's italy
doing with that you know and she's going
to say he's like let me see a map how
close is poland how close is [ __ ]
what do you think they're joining the
russians yeah and i love how i asked my
wife like she's in touch with the
[ __ ] pentagon like she she picks up a
red phone hold on let me see
she's hardwired in what's that what's
biden saying
so so she's like i don't know if we
should take the kids and if this thing
gets hairy so i'm like you know what
let's think about it and then we decided
we're just going to hold off maybe okay
next year but now i see everybody
posting their vacations in italy
everybody's in italy and i saw a guy on
a gondola [ __ ] they were eating and i
just looked at my wife i go we [ __ ] up
but better safe than sorry better
especially with the kids
right so that's so that's the next movie
you're going to go to what's the town in
greece where your family's from where
you're going to go so we want to we want
to actually do like all because i've
never been i've never we're going to i
want to go that [ __ ] looks so nice [ __ ]
yeah so nice i want to go everywhere and
uh yeah i think that my grandfather was
outside outside of athens a little bit
and then um my grandmother was from a
place called taramina in sicily which is
supposed to be some of the nicest
beaches in the world so we were gonna do
that man and uh you know putin so
tommy bastards
when in doubt blame russia i mean yeah
russia or china 100
no so so those are things i want to do
on a page out of my parents book
but the the you know the pool the pool's
gonna happen she said no to the horse
and she said no oh [ __ ] on a horse wait
there's horses up there he just posted a
video the other day [ __ ]
it was like the goddamn kentucky derby
going
just say that she said no to the horse
you never mentioned a horse
oh so i want to get a horse
and uh a racer no i just wanna or chill
just a horse to chill like just to have
a [ __ ] horse you know just because
you're [ __ ] nuts foley what do you
mean to chill to watch the game with you
what are you hanging out sit on it
kids go for it i'll have a [ __ ]
neighbor sit on it take him out get a
horse up there and start riding it
around
giannis neighbor has a horse and she's
got less land than me she's got a stable
one horse she walks around the house she
walks down the street like a dog
she's walking this thing like a [ __ ]
dog i walk actually i walk past her with
my dog i walk past her and she's got
she's got [ __ ] you know sea biscuits
yeah you better clean that [ __ ] up
you're right i know that things just
[ __ ] like like elephant [ __ ] all over
the streets nobody's brutal so stacy
says no you know i talk about in the
special a little bit and then i tried to
get a great dan a great dane without her
blessing
and she that's like a [ __ ] hor that's
a mini horse well she said no to the
horse i want to get the next best thing
so she goes
bobcat
got a cougar she's got me down to a
[ __ ] squirrel at this point
i'm here to deliver a mule to uh mr paul
mercy
what do you what do you want these
donkeys there's something that i will
say if i do get to a level of success i
want an animal nobody's got
dude i'll have a [ __ ] draft lean over
my donny brass go all over imagine
you're feeding a lion
[Laughter]
you imagine we're sitting up on my deck
the giraffe is going to get you to drift
out
get out of here i got friends over go
play i can scream go there go down go
down dude what the [ __ ] man wait when
you say try to get a great dane without
her blessing you almost made a move on
it yeah so how would that happen dude i
do the podcast right i do two podcasts
versus the effect and the one with burr
we were just talking about it and i and
somebody reached out and somebody goes
hey i heard you want a great day and i'm
a breeder in missouri and i love your
stuff and i hook you up and i was like
he's like hooked me up with a dane and i
was like all right so i tell the kids
that this is where i went wrong i go
kids we're getting a puppy and i go what
and i go we're getting a great dane and
lucas goes what about mom i go boring
i got it and then he already knows oh he
knew yeah he knows she calls the shot he
probably didn't even get that upset
because he probably knew right away
oh big time my wife is no sweetheart but
no games
right so then the kid's going mommy's
not going to go for it i go trust me
it's going to happen on christmas she's
not going to be able to say no she's not
gonna be able to say no you know it's
crumb here hey merry christmas she's not
gonna ruin chris here's a puppy he's got
blue eyes
there's a code you gotta play by so i
had a good year financially so i go who
knows like an [ __ ] i'm downstairs i
go who knows what's happening this year
we might get anything for christmas
right just being some stupid and my wife
goes that's great just as long as it's
not another live animal and both of my
kids just go
yeah and ed the right she knows you and
then i go don't worry don't worry and
then then we had to have a talk and she
goes well you bring that [ __ ] thing
in the house she goes we're getting
divorced jesus and i go what she goes
well i would she goes i had a dream we
did my wife had a dream that i against
her will got a great dane and we got
divorced so i go out you know what i'm
gonna yeah gonna maybe maybe maybe that
premonition yeah yeah yeah you know when
your wife's having dreams about you 15
steps what is she the scarlet witch oh
dude my wife dude my wife's got my son
when he was eight she knew where he was
going to college i mean she's one of
those dude i had a dream she goes i had
a dream you got this dog and we just
fought and fought and got divorced and
i'm not saying and i was just like you
know what kids that's because that's
like that's like achievable you know
what i mean that's not like then we went
to mars or whatever and that means that
her stress of it is so much that is
subconsciously sleeping you have the one
dog now right yeah okay so she just
doesn't want another one she doesn't
want another one puppies are a lot
puppies are like puppies your dog is the
[ __ ] thank you but puppies are a lot i
mean i didn't realize what the [ __ ] we
were getting into get into like a year
or something well you want the puppy
because he's cute you want and you want
it to be yours from a baby and grow grow
older i don't want to inherit someone
else's [ __ ] problems either yeah but
18 months they get better yeah yeah but
but see the thing is my wife was like
we're getting rid of them i'd be in a
hotel in in detroit or chicago and she'd
go you're you're calling a friend we got
to get rid of this dog he's jumping he's
biting and i'm just going i just held
and then all of a sudden in 18 months he
just changed nice we got he just he just
turned into he settled down and that's
it but you know she and she's like oh he
loves me and i go yeah he doesn't know
you're a rat because you would have
gotten
yeah
[ __ ] you would have got rid of him
tapes for him how close he was at
[ __ ] getting whacked
yeah i like morty's wigs yeah i was
wearing the wire you don't want to hear
yeah because she was like get rid of him
get rid of him and now she loves them
now oh my god so you know so you will
you you'll just do the pool will you
will you put a new house on no we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna do a
remodel of the house and redo the house
on this property and we're going to get
a point so auditions you're going to
have we're going to add additions we're
talking to contra i already had a
contractor come to the house he looked
we had two contractors come and one goes
i think we should go up and the other
one goes i think we should go back and i
go can we do both
double and then
yeah you actually could do anything you
want so we're gonna do that and and
eventually i think once she gets the
house once the house gets to where i
think i'm gonna get another dog in there
there you go i'll figure it out keep
them in a west wing you know what i mean
well listen if i'm making a certain
amount of money that's when the general
takes that's what i'm the general now
okay you know what
they're calling the [ __ ] shots again
okay what's something in the remodel
that you definitely want to have in the
house you want to have like a bar or a
jacuzzi time i want to have i in the uh
whether
the hot tub will be with the pool oh
you're doing that yeah yeah yeah
i thought he's gonna what do you think
i'm gonna have a [ __ ] inflatable
yeah give me a hundred thousand dollar
pool i'm gonna go to walmart and get one
of those bathtubs
who's got the extension cord got a slip
and slider look real good right next to
the [ __ ] marble pool no i meant in
the bathroom
oh do you already have that now no so
we're gonna do we're gonna do a master
bat we want to do a big big we're gonna
go up and do a big master bedroom with
with the master bath nice up there do
the two sinks the whole nine yards yeah
i want i want i have a lot of sneakers
and it's because it's like overflowing
it's a problem in the house right you
know i got jordans all over the joint
i'm not doing i'm gonna do a room
walk-in closet i wanna do a walk-in
closet with all the sneakers and then
all my stuff that's my stuff
and and do that and then we want a game
room with uh some video games and a pool
table
that's great that's what that's what
additions and expansions of a house yeah
that's what should entail that's nice
yeah that's great yeah yeah i'm not so
we got it you know that's what i'm
looking to do and uh i think once we're
able to do it you know she's got to pipe
down
yeah you don't want a dog yeah well he's
[ __ ] 100 grand for last night so i
got two of them
by the way were you adding shows in
cleveland
out of spite you buy a whole sled dog
team hey i just got a movie dealer
there's a [ __ ] horse in the backyard
now i would never use stuff like that
against her but i would like threaten
her you would think it yeah
stop doing this stop giving me [ __ ] and
go feed the llama will you
busting my balls
uh what'd you do for father's day oh
happy father happy father's day father's
day was incredible man we uh i played
golf in the morning early nice great you
playing up there how did you hit him i
played it i'm good you know i hit him
good i i don't get to play as much as i
want to play but as long as i'm shooting
like mid-90s or you know if i could if i
could shoot 90s or get high 80s without
but without playing a lot sure so we did
that early though 7 30 done by noon you
guys you went out clubs oh yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah i mean
in the golf world you're a real hand job
if you show up i just i just piecing
them together dude it's bad i just said
that the pistol oh that's a little oh
you got like a mini golf putter and [ __ ]
yeah they give you a blue ball
yeah you bring them in a hockey bag you
get the wrong [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
putting them in
do any of the i don't know what they're
called like socks that go on top head
covers yeah
do you have any monogram head covers no
i could see you doing that real nice no
yeah if i played a lot more than i do
now maybe a little paul t versi on the
back
uh who's back on us paul t versus let's
be honest when you just go with the with
the paul t it's class
you know that's on that's on the credit
card paul t
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
my dad my dad his whole you know my dad
you guys know you you you'll see the
special my dad is i mean off the chat my
dad's license plate was tjv always you
know just everything embroidered his
slippers with his [ __ ] my dad has
slippers with his [ __ ] initials on it
that's awesome yeah now he's going to
his [ __ ] bedroom to the bathroom kids
got slippers
golden issues yeah i gotta have custom
slippers
oh that's [ __ ] yeah yeah so this is
in me from him sure
but my mom most italians have it but my
mom's greek watered it sure it like
giannis always says that like you got
because if
he was like yeah dude if you were full
sicilian you go criminal i don't know
about that but but i think
you'd be able to
yeah yeah because i did [ __ ] that was
bad you know i would [ __ ] like as a
kid steal and [ __ ] and like have no
[ __ ]
you know not like i would but i would
steal dumb [ __ ]
you know i didn't i told you you're
stealing
no but i told you
no we broke into cars we would like
break into cars and steal dumb [ __ ] like
banks maserati
or dealership was asking for it we broke
into a couple of houses couple jewelry
boxes kid stuff smashing grab jack put a
gun
back there i put a gun to this old lady
said for a goof it was a goof
yeah she gave me the social security
check but still
we were having fun
i kidnapped it with duct tape for a few
hours it was a joke
you know kid stuff
[Laughter]
no but uh i told the story about the
provolone did i tell you that yeah yeah
yeah i stole 12 alone i would steal
gummy bears a lot
i would always i would put like i would
get i would get drunk and we would go
into stop and shop and i would just
unload [ __ ] in my pants yeah i would
just take handfuls of candy dump them in
my pants you know 40s beers and looking
back i'm like dude where did that couple
because my kids did any [ __ ] like that
yeah
and my mom is like you know but my dad
just is kind of like you know it's
different
it's different now though too it is do
that now
you know there's no hey you know i know
your grandmother you know go home knock
this off or whatever [ __ ] there they
put them to they'd have them they'd
bring them out in cuffs
yeah and it's different now too because
like me and my friends we got hammered
one time and we also want to see
like who could punch themself in the
face the hardest
and we were [ __ ] up in my french
things going boom
yeah
you know and we're watching we're
smoking weed watching then it's the
dumbest thing but now if you told people
you'd they'd be you'd be like what the
[ __ ] these meatheads i know yeah yeah
they go to a trump rally before they
started punching it
well imagine your son getting so [ __ ]
up be like i'm going to start punching
myself what the [ __ ] are you doing like
and you get that phone call yeah you get
that [ __ ] phone call from a mother
like yeah you know i just want to let
you know lucas and them are punching
them beating the [ __ ] out of each other
punching themselves down in the basement
with black guys and maga hats only
uh dude you want to hear something i
took my boy
and four of his friends i took five 13
year old boys to nike stadium all right
there we go these [ __ ] didn't stop
eating dude really i mean i would call
you about 400 can i get off
i wish
i wish dude parents didn't give you any
money no i dropped almost a stack real
dude this kid and i don't you know me of
course as a matter of fact i'll drop a
stack i show i get hot dogs for
everybody [ __ ] i told these [ __ ]
kids m ms whatever you want you tell me
yeah and then moms gave them money
that's another thing i don't do nah okay
you know you give the kill oh my mom
gave me 40 bucks to tell your mother
stop assaulting here give her an extra
20. give her 60 back i'll [ __ ] double
your mother's money what's your mortgage
i'll send a check to your [ __ ] house
i'm going to send it right to the
account what's her car payment what's
she driving
[Laughter]
mr verzi kia just called and said you
took care of him said you took care to
balance it
that's for you enjoy the sorrento will
you
so
so you know one of the kids was like can
we get can we get m m's so and they've
got they're big bags m m's you know like
yes get whatever you want but then i was
like hey man we get crackle jacks and
popcorn like yeah and i just kept going
up to the thing but it was and i just
have to like even when i talk to my wife
it's not about the money i was like i
couldn't watch the game because these
kids wouldn't stop sure sure it's a
[ __ ] three-two count this kid's
asking for a [ __ ] twizzler i'm like
i'm like we got second and third here
okay hey kid i got a parlay going here
okay
you'll get your [ __ ] pretzel bites
when you got them can you hold off that
tapeworm for another half an inning
now is there any part of you
where
you're where are you looking at them to
like exercise a little bit of you know
tact of being like hey you're kind of
pushing it at this point you know what i
mean of like because that was instilled
in us like if somebody if somebody's go
if you're going somewhere and someone's
paying the bill you're not [ __ ]
you're i always said you're not even
your [ __ ] head down and like getting
hey i'll take this and this and then i'm
good
like as far as what i give them as far
as like one of the kids asking hey can i
do this and this and this at some point
really jesus [ __ ] they're always i'll be
honest there's one kid
there's one i mean if we're gonna talk
real yeah you know there's one yeah it's
uh
how much time you guys got i got no
there's one that it's like this thing
where it's like get to you know cause
some of these kids come in the house and
you hear them whisper like hey where you
guys got snacks
it and then i'll hear my son or daughter
go yeah we got a snack oh you got those
two can we get those now me my wife
can't handle it my wife is what's the
rule on that if i'm if i'm one of your
son's friends
holy just wants to come over again
you got dunkaroo's version let me know
right now listen dude the podcast is
doing well what are you watching catch
me breaking in i got a ski mask on i'm
knee deep in dunkaroos
there's a jewelry box right there
is it trailing goldfish into foley's car
give me the pretzel rod what's the rule
on that so what what do you tell the
kids hey when your friends if your
friends come over yeah if you guys want
a snack you ask me your mommy or just go
in the pantry get whatever you want how
do you guys play stacy's along with the
rule and stacy's like look you take one
baby she wants him eating rice she's
like the nutritionist yeah of course
like take one bit like you know if we
know the kids ate lunch and they're full
you know you take one bag of snacks
everybody gets to go outside and play
and that's it but then you get the kids
who go harder who are like hey man i saw
that you also had we got a candy and
then whatever my kids are like me they
don't want to ever be like no sure you
know that's a good kid you know yeah
they don't want it so they're like all
right hold on and then stacy will see
extra rappers and go what the [ __ ]
happened and and my kids like you know
so and so i'll just use a name and
you're like oh joey just and my wife's
like i don't give and then that's the
thing so when you go to a game you could
see what that kid's doing of course yeah
you know why do you think they're not
getting that at home and this is there's
something and and there's something
there's i also think it comes from the
parents a little bit like does your kid
wouldn't go it does oh now i'll do the
scoop of ice cream and let me get two
ipa's and i'm [ __ ] whatever i mean
your kid would be like i'll do it a
slice of pizza and a soda and we'll call
it that yeah i had a [ __ ] 12 year old
with a [ __ ] shrimp cocktail
this kid's getting sushi from the
[ __ ] section
i love the tuna tartare the [ __ ] you
will
get your goddamn mind give him the
twizzlers
yeah
and here's what i did here's what i did
walking in and this is all true this is
all [ __ ] true he's funny i don't i
don't say [ __ ] like this just to say it
we walked into that [ __ ] ballpark and
there was everybody real steak real not
not chopstick not like where you guys
come from the the cheese cheese steak
yeah chop no no there was steaks that
they put on sandwiches on heroes
so these kids were getting sirloins on
steaks and then they put whatever they
want i made sure every kid got a big
steak sandwich with whatever they wanted
on
probably 18 bucks a clip it was
okay
before we sat down and they all had
drinks before we sat down so they got a
steak sandwich drinks not to mention on
the ride from upstate to yankee stadium
the car's just littered with snacks okay
okay so yeah it was like i got to
mention a parking down there either yeah
that ain't cheap yeah that ain't
freezing so these kids got steak in
their bellies they got food they got
snacks everything sit down and then i
just and but you could tell the ones
where i'm just like as they kept asking
i was just like dude your parents suck
yeah exactly it comes from them your old
man work what's going on
is he laid off or something they
furlough him this is great he's still
collecting what's happening this kid's
asking me for a new book bag it's it's
something that you know it's a problem
because the kids come from money or have
money and it's like a take thing and it
was actually i use it as an example to
tell my kids like like you don't my kids
my kids know listen if you're hungry
somebody gives you pizza you have a
couple slices too you get full you have
a drink
don't ask for [ __ ] tupperware to take
it home you know
i can't have slice wrapped up yeah kid
comes with a half a box or something i'm
like you asked for this it's funny
because those are the ones that are
greedier and not even greed's the right
word maybe but like the kids that you
know might be a little bit less off than
the versies they're usually the nicer
more polite more oh my god thank you so
much yeah it's these [ __ ] rich kids
you got to watch out for yeah and
there's always a pr like see this is the
one thing i know about having a 10 year
old and a 13 year old is you're
responsible
when you're on the clock with with them
you're responsible for that kid's life i
know yeah and and this you know they'll
come in and be like oh my god thank you
for taking joe here's his medicine i'm
like medicine
i was like what the [ __ ] are you handing
me here
i'll text my wife and be like i'm not
giving this you're certified in cpr
right mr version what the [ __ ] yeah
you're looking squeamish at needles are
you
we're going to see
want to see the avengers talking about
it yeah and you'll get like ziploc bags
of medicine and [ __ ] and you just ah
he's never gonna need it that's why
he'll never need it i'll never know but
if he does there's a scalpel in there
you gotta cut his leg off
you know how to do an emergency trick
right
you got to take his leg before the blood
flows there okay you're going for a bag
of peanuts you're diving over the [ __ ]
i remember we had that
my boy going to lacrosse camp
my boy going to lacrosse camp we get on
the bus and his mom [ __ ] hands my
buddy eric his epi pen oh [ __ ] epipens i
felt like they they got invented in like
20 20 you know they're they're new oh
listen he's allergic to life yeah
you don't have air in the house do you
there's not water in that pool is there
version
don't you guys don't have porcelain
toilets do you guys got horses by any
chance over there he's allergic to
equestrians
uh yeah so so those are things that um
and but i am i really do love it man
bless you buddy i love it
i love you know i'm a kid man so i love
taking them to the arcade i love taking
them to games you're having fun with it
damn like when i'm not doing shows man i
just want to be what my kids do yeah and
i'm not just saying that like i just hey
man let's sit down let's watch the game
together let's do something i just love
being with my family man so yeah um good
guy he is a classy guy we've talked
about this privately you know dudes like
you
yanny the things that you're doing
that's you know where we see you know
that's that's that's the you know you
guys have the secret you know i mean you
have the best you have the life you're
not you know it's not you have like 14
roommates and you know you're
stabbing someone in the back to get a
spa a check spot somewhere you know a
nice piece of property the family what
happens is and you're gonna fi you're
gonna find this i'm sorry you're gonna
find this is that um
it's the thing and i always told kevin
this one we would work together um
because we're surrounded by children
don't let anybody don't let anybody know
he's like we're in an industry full of
kids don't let anybody tell you not to
get married right away 20 minutes off
the bat yeah don't don't tell anybody
that you can't have a real life in this
and have family and kids and what you
think matters and is important doesn't
we're running around these [ __ ]
[ __ ]
are these [ __ ] love getting missed
you worked out these [ __ ] dummies
we're still talking about that kid joey
jesus christ
taking these a bag of m's
no but they running around for 25 spots
to a booker or an owner that's never
lived in our shoes i was before pandemic
i i said to my wife i go okay i would
leave my dinner table on a [ __ ]
tuesday at six o'clock my kids going
where you go oh i got to go down and
[ __ ] do a 25 spot but i didn't
realize the hamster wheel that i was on
sure and and the more successful you get
too you're gonna you don't you picking
you [ __ ]
you choose you hear that out there you
you pick and choose when and it's right
for you and what makes you feel good
because at the end of the day dude when
you're [ __ ] sitting there god forbid
on in a hospital going i [ __ ] left my
babies i left my [ __ ] family to go do
a [ __ ] bar show in [ __ ] long
island city on a wednesday night for
[ __ ] food for for a [ __ ] chicken
what the [ __ ] no that that's the hell
that's hell that's not living you know
and and it's also somebody that we're
trying to impress a stranger how crazy
they trying to impress a [ __ ]
stranger you just left all your loved
ones to if that booker got smacked by a
[ __ ] bus and explode died miserably
the next day there'll be another one oh
what's his name oh gr oh greg does he
like my type of comment that's that's a
sickness so i just got to the point
where i was like listen i gotta trust
the process know that believe in myself
getting better knowing that and doing it
on my terms my way and and that made
everything fall into place because when
you show people that when you show
people like look look i know you have a
whole little system you got no i'm not
i'm not playing that guy i'm i'm not a
player
no you know i said you know i haven't
told this story many times on a podcast
and i don't care if any but what anybody
thinks about i don't give a [ __ ] let's
go uh you know with the comedy seller
you know uh years ago i got in i got an
audition at the comedy seller this is
like 10 11 years ago and i did well but
they were just like playing the game
like oh we don't know we'll see we'll
see you know i saw him very late maybe
i'll see him early like 11 12 years ago
and i said okay so i'm not going to play
the game anymore because i thought i did
well and this is nothing against them
they've been great to me now but years
go by and i go i'm not going to go back
there until they call me and i go you go
what i go i'm not going to do the comedy
seller until they hear about me enough
to where they call me and they say
you're gonna we want you to work here
i'm not auditioning
and i did the stand and i did new york
comedy club and i did all these places
and i come home one day and i put that
out there to the world and i look at my
phone and i got a text from estee the
booker and she goes hey you know we have
a club in vegas that's opening at the
rio and comics are saying that you
should do it and i heard from bobby
kelly that you should do it we'd love to
have you do it and i said great and she
goes in the meantime if you want to do
any of our new york rooms give me your
avails and i gave my veils and they
loaded me up with shows and i've been
there and i've been there for years it's
like that that i'm not do i'm not doing
nothing listen to me i'm not [ __ ]
doing anything i'm not doing for you i'm
doing it for me and my family that's it
that's it of course yeah and i sleep
good mm-hmm i'm buying i don't know why
i just porter has sandwiched i think i'm
coming down here
yeah and and and i realized that it's
almost like to the abuse you take well
that's that's sure that's what we're
realizing now is we you know we
gained some success it's like i or at
least i am and you know it's like you're
you're beholden to every single person
when even like from an open when you can
get on stage to do a check spot to doing
a guest spot to doing a regular spot to
you know opening up for something like
everything
is decided by someone else yeah in the
industry
a booker uh club manager whatever
to the point now where i'm like oh i
don't need
we've made all of this outside of the
anything you know what i mean like this
is all just based on the [ __ ] fans
listening so yeah that's all we need the
bozos in the house yeah i'm like
everybody can [ __ ] suck a dick and
there's nothing i have what we need yeah
and there's nothing wrong with like
what i said is nothing against the
seller or any comedy club that i want to
work of course now it's just like oh i
got to a point where it's like okay
people are talking about me and i'm kind
of passed everywhere else for me to go
and and audition for six minutes when i
remember once it just didn't make sense
and then her hearing about it and i give
sd credit cause she goes who's this paul
version i hear about and then she
actually [ __ ] booked me sure so it's
like so so it was actually and and
that'll happen other places you know
when you say no in this business
it's like people everything that i ever
thought everything i ever dreamed of
has happened with with things where it's
like people out there hey man i'd love
to have you come and do my show
back in the day you're like i need work
yeah i need horses i'll do anything i'll
stand on a [ __ ] beer crate and tell
jokes in some bar now all of a sudden
but it's just it's just putting the work
in and doing it and getting better i
mean then you have to be you know
immensely talented
and good looking
i mean you have to be [ __ ] hilarious
but i mean no of course but you always
did that that was always shocking to me
you always held yourself
tell your ground you held your ground
which i've learned a lot of confidence
to say no having the confidence to step
off the hamster wheel and just go
through that even things even get better
i mean when the pandemic was happening
like all these shows were happening here
and there and like all outdoor kind of
stuff and he was like we went down to
the stress factory and opened for you at
the stretch factory i had like this big
tent and everything goes i'll do this
i'll do this you ain't gonna find me
standing on the back of a [ __ ] pickup
truck at a [ __ ] vineyard he's like
i'm not doing that i'm not gonna be
staying in central park next to a
[ __ ] batting
i'm like swatting the squirrels away in
the morning
i'm going like i was in the thing of
like oh you got to get on stage you got
to [ __ ] go tell jokes in the park you
got to do this i was doing the icu what
are you talking about he's going i'm not
doing nine shows already these kids are
standing there with [ __ ] radio shack
karaoke machines in central park i mean
[ __ ] screaming
yeah that's it you gotta you gotta be
more you know uh because whatever
divisive yeah the mentality of it is is
the mentality of it is is wild man
where's the wisdom it yeah words of
[ __ ] wisdom
smart guy died
dude you could write a book called doing
it right the paul versus way to live it
yeah dude i'm let's do it
what do you want 10 percent [ __ ] call
my lawyer by paul verzie forward by paul
verzie
published by paul versus publisher but
you know what i went to the danilo poole
contractors
shout out to ashley what would you name
the horse
oh and would you wear nikes while you
wrote it yes oh really
i would be in jordan threes on that
[ __ ] for sure i'd put looking
like little nas x up there i'd put
jordan horseshoes on [ __ ] horse
there would be a jordan logo on the
horseshoe i'm sorry i would call
jordan's company and be like can we do
that
all right a pair of air maxes listen to
philly
the air sea biscuits listen i'm trying
to give this kid a stroll today you got
any [ __ ]
gold jordan
but i will say this though as much as i
sit here and i'm like hey i want to do
things my way and i'm not going to do
things that i feel like you know will
hurt my my worth or what i feel i'm
worth you know is you know followers
because there are things that i don't do
you know like my social media thing and
it wasn't like it wasn't uh i'm too cool
for that it wasn't that but it was like
i i really was having a hard time doing
certain things that tick-tock made
tick-tock go sure you know like i'm oh
this guy and i'm not knocking that's the
other thing i'm never gonna knock
somebody that caught something or
they're cooking or they're doing
something or doing man on the street
stuff but for me it was like look i just
want to put good stand up out you know
maybe do some acting do some good clips
and yeah i'll do some funny stuff here
or there but i wasn't the
i wanted
fame
and money to be a byproduct of being of
being great at what you do
as opposed to right and then yes so it's
like oh i love that hour i love that
stand up oh i love that acting that they
did hey i wanted it to build that way we
live in a time now where attention span
is [ __ ] really sure that's why
baseball speaking of baseball that's why
baseball's not doing baseball's not
doing good because a kid looks at a tick
tock for 14 seconds and he's you know
and that's it now they're going to watch
it you know they're going to watch
bullpen changes and do this and that
they don't have that which is wild the
older i get the more i [ __ ] love me
too just sitting there for a couple
hours so you don't want to do like the
uh you know uh comedian with impeccable
beard and beautiful gold chain destroys
hector those aren't the kind of videos
you want to be doing yeah and how many
times does that guy destroy that's the
funny how many hecklers are coming to
your show
you got a [ __ ] youtube channel a
heckler you got the worst luck in
america
this motherfucker's got the worst luck
in america he was in memphis last night
somebody puked on stage that he was in
cincinnati a guy [ __ ] his pant well some
something's wrong with this guy this
guy's got the worst luck in the world or
he's got [ __ ] plants what's happening
the [ __ ] out
a horse hit the stage i don't know what
check out my youtube channel and see if
i if i lived
comedian destroys grizzly bear that runs
in his showroom
i had a heart attack it's on patreon
it's on patreon that's a bad idea see if
i see if i survived i'm i'm going to be
we're taking an idea and cutting it
shout out to samyam and jack conte we
love you i don't listen to this guy's
bonkos i mean some of these guys will do
[ __ ] quadruple bypass surgeries on
their youtube channel
[Laughter]
yeah i'm in room 232 mount sinai it's on
my patreon
i love it which we will be doing
shout out to the people you hear about
foley's new show no he's in a hospital
bed i swear to god
[Laughter]
colonoscopy on the street
all right
this was on our last episode
um it was actually the clip we did i
would love to get your take on it would
you ever sleep in the bed that someone
died in no never no i can't [ __ ] with it
if it was like i won't go into a house
where uh nah when it comes to listen
when it comes to demonic
listen to me when it comes to demonic
spiritual [ __ ] any kind of other realm
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] with busters no no any
kind of other realm [ __ ] i don't i don't
even want to tempt i don't want to
attempt any [ __ ] any kind of you
don't be real
that's what i said i'm no no listen i'm
not real superstitious heebie jeebies
but that takes a different kind of guy
to lay in a dead man's bed dude if a guy
got his arm cut off in a ferrari and
they detailed the ferrari and we'll give
it to him i wouldn't take it no no i
just can't that was like who was it the
james
killed like nine people yeah redoing the
car and it just kept [ __ ] murdering
him yeah yeah i don't like any of that
[ __ ] so no i would definitely know you
would never do like a haunted house tour
oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that dude you kidding me dude i
would [ __ ] i would me and bobby kelly
got into an argument about that he said
we had a thing would you rather you know
when i used to do gun to your head would
you rather be out in the woods one night
darkness you have like you have enough
to live so you got a couple [ __ ] granola
bars a couple waters you'll get through
the 24 hours as far as nutrition and
meals nice bottle of wine but you have
to get you have to sleep you have to
figure out to sleep if it rains you're
just out there you're out there so
you're in the woods survivor-esque
yeah but you still but you have clothes
you have stuff you have stuff but you're
out there for 24 hours pitch black in
the woods you got to make it through 24
hours in that or stay in a legitimate
and i said a legitimate haunted house
and i said uh i would absolutely go in
the woods and i think bobby was like
bobby was like [ __ ] that i go dude
you're gonna see a little rocking a girl
rocking on a horse or whatever you go
yes i'll [ __ ] close my eye he he said
he would not he said he would stay
that's crazy dude if i saw a [ __ ]
rocking horse with a little girl in a
cup a rocking chair yeah you would rock
it you know yeah
i got anything rocking that's not moving
here hi paulie yeah
yeah [ __ ] that but i get scared of the
water i would try to give her something
though i'd be like dude here's a chain
comedian heckled by ghost dude
how's the last time you're in a yankee
game honey
i got a little boy about your age come
on we'll all go i'll give her i could
try to give her nikes i'm like here no
no i can't that [ __ ] like that i can't
do it i get scared of the woods too
supernaturally for some reason when i'm
standing in the woods looking out i
swear i see something like move but
would you rather go in the woods for 24
hours and have to fend for yourself or
would you go in the haunted house that
you knew you would hear something i
would be i would be sk i would be more
scared of supernatural things getting me
in the woods than a bear or something
there is no way he's on a different kind
of crazy there's no way getting into a
whole other there's no way on earth i
would ever stay in a hornet there's no
just just like i'm not [ __ ] with that
we did it supposedly
the oh in allentown yeah but there was
nine of us in a room and cotton was
snoring so loud that no ghosts were
getting through that yeah i'll tell you
that right now
yeah no i um
i i mean i'm superstitious but i don't
like you know i'm not only people that
walk in the room it's like oh i feel an
energy here not that at all i'm not my
fourth senses aren't strong i don't know
i definitely walked into rooms and been
like i don't like it well we just did
that if it's cold or so something's up i
go this don't feel let's throw this
ain't kosher
yeah
yeah something's not right the hotel we
went into the hotel we stayed in in
detroit i walked into the room
and
it was just something the ac wasn't
working it was warm it had like a funny
smell but there was like an energy in
there yeah i was like i'm adding i think
that happens at uh hotels sometimes when
like there hasn't been enough time since
the person left you're like i still feel
the other guy or some hooker got killed
in there so you could and and i think
that um
premonitions like that are real yeah if
i ever felt like the roof if i was ever
somewhere where the room all of a sudden
got cold i would freak out and [ __ ]
immediately run to a catholic church
well i'll tell you guys i bathe in a
hole did i i'll tell you guys the story
it really happened my mom it freaked my
mom out and we talk about it sometimes
but it was a really weird thing when i
was in um i might have told this on a
long long time ago so but um your
listeners
probably i'm sure somebody experienced
this when it comes to premonition i was
in 10th grade and i would smoke
cigarettes so smoking those marlboro
mediums and [ __ ] and i said to my mom it
was around 10 o'clock i said i'm gonna
go outside and that's when you had like
the discman oh yeah you know so i'm
going to go outside let's see
so you were 16 you would go outside and
smoke with your disc man on i would go
outside and i was yeah maybe it might
have been the yellow one no i think my
no mine was a blue sony one it was a
blue sony one i went outside i just told
my mom my mom was just like you got to
stop smoking i go out smoke and i'm
sitting there and this is upstate this
is upstate new york further than west
chester's in dutchess county not far
from poughkeepsie and i'm sitting this
is all real dude and uh [ __ ] my family
up so i'm sitting there and my mother
said before i left she goes i don't want
you have any friends here i don't want
any friends don't are you are you going
like she did the thing are you going out
to smoke a cigarette because your
friend's gonna pull up and you guys are
gonna [ __ ] stuff or your friend in
the neighborhood i go i owe i'm smoking
a cigarette i'm gonna listen to music
i'll be in 20 minutes sitting there dude
and i uh looked over and there was an
issue with the other house with a spirit
there was an issue with the other house
with the spirit and i'm out and and uh
my brother saw it my older brother saw
something when nobody was home moving
paulie thanks for coming by again
they're special
so start throwing holy water so anyway
but i don't know if i don't know if it
had anything to do with that your
brother said you saw it bring your
brother my brother saw something the the
the the mother-in-law of the of the
people the mother of the woman that
lived there says somebody was sitting on
her lap that wasn't like that she felt
the pressure of someone left that wasn't
and it was something that was an ongoing
thing we helped them move and a door
slammed and they were like oh is it that
chick again like it was like that was
i'm out i'll get the pizza so but i
don't know if my premonition
is related to that but that was a
situation and we think that that's why a
lot of things happen weird in the house
even with the marriage they moved and
stuff anyway i'm sitting now i'm smoking
a cigarette and i'm just looking out
it's dark and i just get this horrible
horrible [ __ ] feeling from the right
and then i don't know if it's like when
you're a kid you know you're running and
you start running fast because you maybe
i don't know if it's that but i'm just
sitting there and i look over it's just
dark bushes black bushes and i'm just
like
you know bugging to stop it you know
then i start doing the thing stop being
a [ __ ] okay you're in 10th grade you
know what i mean you're in high school
and i'm looking and there's just
something
so i look down to should i just grab my
stuff and go right i had that feeling
and that's when i said i go [ __ ] this
man stop it
and dude i swear to god i got my [ __ ]
together i started smoking a cigarette
and then all of a sudden an overwhelming
feeling said you gotta get the [ __ ] up
and you gotta get out right now and i
look down to grab my [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] door pops open and it's my
mother and she goes i [ __ ] i told you
not to have any friends here and i go
what and she said and we took she goes i
just saw your friend in the white hat
run to the side of the house and dude i
[ __ ] said
dude i go what and she goes i go stuff i
i almost was like are you dude i ran
inside i told her my stuff i'm getting
the children i told her in the
stepfather my my stepfather's story and
um
to this day i was actually eating with
my mother this is this is that long ago
and i'm eating with my mother not long
ago my mother said do you remember my
mother goes do you remember when when
she goes i saw she goes she said to me
like recently she goes i saw somebody
run past there and i had just looked and
it was black dude my insides told me to
get the [ __ ] out you knew you felt it
and for that reason so when your
listeners write that in it's like i'm
not [ __ ] with anything i don't [ __ ]
with it that okay i want new give me a
new bed a new [ __ ] house i know
nobody even sat on it yeah i don't even
like if somebody i like i don't want to
be nuts but like i don't want somebody
to try the shoes on a foot locker before
i don't like that either that gives me
the heebie-jeebies i'm like how many
people are trying out tens how do i know
this guy's still alive huh dude you know
what you're hit by a bus walking out
there
got me wearing dead man shoes by the way
my headphones cut out right before you
said the thing about the guy in the
white hat i'm officially freaked out
right now
yeah that's a true story man and that
really that was something because i saw
nothing
i saw nothing and my mother said i you
know that's what really did it dude so
anyway i'll let you get to no no jeez
that that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up my sister had
it at her house the guy died in the
house like it was an old couple yeah the
guy died in the house and then
he was talking to the kids because
apparently kids have a more
connected whatever to that universe or
that whatever what
and yeah he was talking to all the kids
and they had a party
and he was talking to kids to the kids
and this is because well this kid was
this girl was playing by herself
downstairs she was like four or
something something's a little [ __ ] up
with the kids though too no no
no because she was like why they're like
why aren't you playing upstairs with all
the other kids and they were like
playing nintendo you know where you guys
[ __ ] stop staring at me you're
[ __ ] sick kids sitting here
stop rolling your eyes in the back of
your head
yeah playing pin the talent donkey what
the [ __ ] you doing here talking to this
guy
rest his soul see i got to say rest
yourself that's the guinean
all right
so so what happened to the kid no so the
kid was just downstairs playing by
herself and the other kids were upstairs
or so and she's like yeah the man told
me to go down the man told me no kids i
never would have went back to that house
again yeah that would and so then what
was he making eggs like what was it no
he was upstairs like in the bedroom was
where he passed or whatever so then my
girl goes to my sister and she's like
what man they go up and my sister's like
all right so like
we have had instances with a guy
upstairs if i went to somebody's house
so they had to have like a [ __ ]
seance and like burn sage and like you
ask him to leave and all that stuff like
i would want to know that i would want
to before i went to the house i don't
[ __ ] sleep there i get out of there
before a [ __ ] sun goes down like
christmas i'm gone dude i had us i had
something happen i i even see i feel
weird saying this that's how nuts it is
that i feel weird i'll [ __ ] say no no
talking about a pocket i had a kid put
that evil on us yeah he goes i was into
uh i was out in a [ __ ] movie and my
buddy goes dude you come out to la you
come out to la do you sleep in my room i
sleep on the couch anyway
you know and i was like yeah that's
really nice and he goes yeah my
bedroom's a couch he's a big baseball
guy who would watch baseball all the
time so i i decline and we [ __ ] go to
his house and we're playing poker and
everyone at the poker table goes dude
why is your bedroom
the living room how come you don't go in
the bedroom he goes ah dude i think it's
haunted i go you [ __ ] invited me what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what am i what is it i never want to
talk to him again what am i bait jesus
christ yeah i'm gonna see if verse he
makes it out
if i go into the bedroom and paul he's
sticking to the ceiling
i'm gonna cancel the
he [ __ ] elevates and twists like
stranger things did you see stranger
things enough yeah i'm watching the news
you like the new one the new season yeah
i like the old seasons a little bit
better but i'm a big um what's his name
the sheriff guy oh there wasn't enough
hopper for me i like hopper in that down
and out situation yeah yeah i mean yeah
yeah i like him couple of drinks that
snub those 38 [ __ ] hitting guys oh
yeah you're an old school yeah yeah oh
yeah
opera's all right
um all right we gotta we gotta wrap up
here we got comments let's just do uh
yeah get us off of his coocher i know
something nice puppies or something uh
this is from braxton have you ever been
to a wax museum
and have you taken a picture with with
one of them i have i have never been to
all version the rock
you making your facebook picture
he's a great guy
get my arm around kevin hart
um you met warren beatty
[Laughter]
[ __ ] uh i have never been to a wax
museum nor do i have any it is the
trashiest of trash i went as a kid and i
even i was like seven i was looking to
my dad i'm like we don't belong yeah
this is for other kind of people it's
funny when you go to something like that
like like a renaissance fair or some
[ __ ] or like you know
guys with swords and [ __ ] taking it
seriously
and like that's that's a different dude
that's a different different kind of guy
because these people were like lined up
to watch a real joust yeah and i'm like
dude that guy works at [ __ ] mavis
when he's not when he's happy already
he's not doing when he's not a [ __ ]
funny guy takes off his arm he changes
my wheels takes off his armor next thing
he's [ __ ]
can we speed up the joust i gotta get i
gotta get to the night shift
i got an install in 20 minutes i'm gonna
get that one i gotta get back to the
mall ah
i like a nice renaissance fair that's
different than a
bit so no wax
a little better you get a kid a shield
and [ __ ] you get out of there
you get a turkey leg and a shield and
you get the [ __ ] on you're eating a big
turkey leg in a wax museum you're
[ __ ] trash
i'll tell you that right now
a turkey like anywhere is trash
the body part of an animal
i'm holding a turkey leg in one hand the
other arms around whoopi goldbergs
let's wrap it up
ladies and gentlemen mr palmers check
out this special on netflix goddammit oh
[ __ ] buddy we [ __ ] love you thank you
so much for coming uh june 23rd man june
23rd man my special on netflix nocturnal
admissions it's 64 minutes and uh i'm
i'm really happy with it it's a [ __ ]
killer go check it out check it out and
check out the version effect podcast and
uh
yeah it's out right now because this
comes out on thursday this will come out
wednesday night on youtube so if you're
on the east coast if you're on the east
coast three o'clock in the morning yeah
there you go set the alarm do the
reminder subscribe can't thank you guys
enough man i know you know i can't thank
you i know your podcast is dope and the
fact that you guys let me come on isn't
it
i've been trying to get you back for a
month like yeah when the special column
we kept kicking me down i said god damn
no you guys are the best man keep
rolling thank you buddy kippy what do
you got for him guys uh our live show
dates are on sale the link's in the
description we got t-shirts the patreon
check everything the [ __ ] out there
jersey come see us first august 11th we
love you we'll see you next week